What happens when 800 of the world’s most elite footballers
and their managers live together under one roof?
Players stop being polite
and start getting Real.
This is
The Champions
I'm one of the best players in the world...
according to my paycheck.
People say I would be good in the Premier League,
but first I need to be good in Serie A.
Thanks, Kepa, but, ugh, we actually need a Champions League goalkeeper.
So, ugh, if you could just, ugh, go ahead and get off the set.
It was just a cramp. I'm staying. You can't make me go!
Zizou's back! Isco be alright.
I can't sleep.
I haven't slept since that day. We were in total control.
Then he took it away. My question is...
Who decided on the sizes of the paintings?
I am an L.
No, Antoine. You are not an L.
You only need cojones in your heart.
Huh?
Come on, let's talk somewhere else that doesn't smell like a Porto-Potty.
Look, you're great, Antoine.
Your hair deserves to be up there with the legends.
But do you?
Why not?! I'm just as good as Ronaldo and Messi!
...At what?
I won the World Cup!
Mbappe won the World Cup. Now shut up and follow me.
Ah, the book no one reads.
Whoa! Encroyable...
OK, so apparently there's some kind of secret fight club
going on in the basement.
Gentlemen, welcome to Fight-letico.
Yeah, so we never told Antoine about the secret fight club
because he's always got thousands of cameras following him.
Oh wait, f--k.
The first rule of Fight-letico is:
You do not talk about Fight-letico...
unless a streaming service offers you a lot of money.
Uh huh.
Got it.
Like how much money?
The second rule of Fight-letico is:
IF you do talk about Fight-letico
because a streaming service offered you a lot of money,
don't take tax advice from your family.
Smart.
Totally.
But like, seriously, like how much money?
The third rule of Fight-letico:
To get a red card for violent conduct is easy.
To get your opponent sent off for doing nothing—
that is the work of a true assh--e.
This is the real Madrid...Atletico style.
I know I'm not an Atletico player,
but they told me they had a safe space for violence.
Uh, yes please.
Whoa.
Haha, I know. It's f--king intense.
Uh...ouch.
Finish him.
I came back for this!
Alright. I'm ready now.
You gotta play to the whistle, Antoine.
Look at that red-card virgin.
Hey, what's going on, tough guys?
Grabbing your cojones?
This is you. This is what you look like.
And this is what you look like.
I knocked you out of the Champions League,
and I can knock you out right here.
OK, I didn't touch him.
Stop shaking your heads disapprovingly. People love me.
You all love me, right?
Not cool, man.
But without love I am just a shell.
A really, really good-looking, talented shell!
Wow. You are...shameless.
I am legend.
And legends need trophies!
Okay, bye!
Good fight, man.
Good fight.
(whispering)
Wait. What did you say about mi madre?!